my father says never is a very powerful
powerful word word
you said we've never been paranoid are
you saying never as in 1776 or never as
in 40 years 60 years 80 years 100 years
well i'm speaking relative terms
compared to the north koreans and the
chinese and the russians and our
contemporary adversaries i don't think
we've ever
been as paranoid as they
and including founding fathers oh
including founding fathers if we
understand maybe we're using the word
paranoid in different ways i mean a
paranoid paranoia is a dysfunctional
psychological condition
that means that you live in a fantasy
world where you imagine that you are
surrounded by threats some of them may
be real but many of them are not
and i think
i don't think that describes america in
any phase of its history if anything we
have been a nation of optimists
throughout uh the founding fathers take
them as an example you know
uh you know uh they had i would describe
them as very optimistic people because
they believed
uh
you know they believed that uh god
intended men to be free
which i think is true
you know they believed in the ability of
human beings to
use rational rationalism to govern
themselves which is why we had the
american revolution
uh you know the amer the whole reason
for the american revolution
it was a a a
a a gamble on human optimism you know on
on the ability of human beings to be
free
that you didn't need to have a monarchy
basically a tyranny in order to have a
good society in order to keep order in
society that people were capable uh
you know
in a very decentralized way because the
founders vision of of what america
should be
is very different from what it is today
but they had had this vision of a
federalism with a small f
where
people would be governing themselves in
their hamlets and their villages and
that's where most governance would take
place
and then at the level of the states okay
that would be the next level and the
least
amount of power was supposed to be in
the federal government in washington
this is a revolution in the way men were
supposed to be governed you know not a
top-down system where a king is deciding
everything for you and it's implemented
on ministers and your peasants are just
supposed to obey you know what an
optimistic vision of human nature and of
and of how to build a good society and
uh throughout our our our history we
have uh we have believed in that look at
our trust in bringing immigrants into
this country you know even though uh uh
you know there were lots of prejudices
and biases we had this faith in in the
ability of human beings to use
rationalism and to enjoy freedom so that
we would bring in
catholics uh immigrants of of different
races uh and and that we could put them
all together in this mix uh you know and
it would all work in america it would
make america uh not only would make it a
better place and an even freer and more
prosperous place and they were and they
were right you know uh they were right
for anyway for a long time uh you know
the system seems to be breaking down
today but that's not because the
founders were wrong about the
fundamentals it's because we have
forgotten the fundamentals so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]